PROFESSOR: --wind up doing a
substantial part of Chapter
11, although I do tend to
be over-optimistic.
So we're handing out Chapter 11,
which I expect to revise
still further.
As we get towards these end
chapters, these are things
I've only taught from, at most,
once before, and so I
have more revisions to do than
the earlier chapters which
I've used for many years.
The Problem Set Seven, as we
announced last time, you only
needed to hand in the first four
problems today, so we're
only handing out the solutions
for the first four today.
I haven't made up any additional
problems, so
Problem Set Eight is simply to
do the last two problems in
Problem Set Seven, due
next Wednesday.
And a reminder that we have no
class on Monday because of
this peculiar local holiday we
have called Patriot's Day,
when we run the marathon.
And I hope you'll all be out
there running the marathon.
So enjoy the long weekend.
So what have we been doing
in Chapter 10?
We've basically been getting
minimal trellis realizations,
or state-state space
realizations, in system theory
terms, for linear block codes.
We've been focusing on binary
linear block codes, but
clearly everything we've been
doing goes to block codes over
any finite field or,
in fact, over the
real or complex field.
It's just basic realization
theory,
minimal realization theory.
So as long as we have a linear
time-varying system, it works.
I had a question after class
last time, well, doesn't it
work just as well for
nonlinear systems?
Can't we do the trellis
in the same way?
In general, not.
If it's a nonlinear system
with a group
property, then you can't.
It's really the group property
that's key to these
constructions.
And we seem to have pretty
well cracked the problem.
We have this tool called
the trellis-oriented or
minimal-span generator matrix,
from which we can read all the
parameters of the trellis,
from which we
can construct a trellis.
Really, we found that the
trellis-oriented generator
matrix contains all the
information we need to
construct a minimal trellis.
And it's just a matter
of turning the crank
once we have that.
The only degree of freedom that
I've allowed so far in
trellis constructions
is sectionalization.
I've shown you that if we can
choose where to put the state
spaces wherever we like--
typically we put them in the
center and other places,
sometimes we put them everywhere
we could put them,
that's called an unsectionalized
trellis--
and by so doing, we can
sometimes reduce the apparent
state-space complexity.
But we can never reduce
the branch complexity.
So we're left with branch
complexity as a fundamental
complexity parameter
for linear block
codes, or so it seems.
Is there any other--
yes?
AUDIENCE: Does the complexity of
the number of computations
you need to go through the
trellis depends only on the
number of branches, right?
PROFESSOR: It depends primarily
on the number branches.
It also depends on the edges.
If you go through a detailed
operation count, I think I
give the formula for if you
count additions and
comparisons as an addition and
selection you don't count as a
logical operation, then I think
the total count for the
Viterbi algorithm is twice the
number of edges in the graph,
which is the number of branches,
minus the number of
vertices, which you lose
one for every--
AUDIENCE: What do you
mean by vertices?
PROFESSOR: By vertices I mean
states, now I'm talking about
it as a graph.
Minus one or plus one
or something.
So that's an exact count for
the Viterbi algorithm.
But it's dominated by the total
number of edges in the
graph which, in turn, is
well-estimated by the maximum
branch complexity
at any one time.
So there's a bit of a trade-off
between an exact
count and just getting a gross
handle on the situation.
But I say it's certainly got
to exceed the branch
complexity.
So when I find the branch
complexity goes up
exponentially, even for one
branch, then I know that the
total Viterbi algorithm
complexity has to go up
exponentially with that.
All right?
So is that the whole story?
Do we now have a pretty
definitive handle on the,
quote, complexity of at least
maximum likelihood decoding,
trellis decoding of
a block code.
And if you've read Chapter 11,
you know there's one other
degree of freedom that we
haven't exploited yet in
representing a linear
block code.
Anyone read that far, or are you
just going to wait for me
to explain it to you?
Flip the coordinates,
very good.
Could that make a difference?
Yes, it certainly could.
Let's take our standard example
by now, the 8-4-4 code
with trellis-oriented matrix
that looks like this.
OK, and we know everything
about this by now.
But suppose, say, we flip these
two center coordinates.
Certainly it would be an
equivalent code from all of
its n, k, d and that
sort of properties.
So I want to take these two
coordinates and make them 1,
1, 1, 0, 0, 1, 1, 1.
Let's suppose that's a
trellis-oriented generator
matrix for the code.
I think it is.
It's got starting times here,
here, here, and now here.
And it's got ending times now
here, here, here, and here.
OK.
Where I introduce the diverging
and merging symbols
that I used last time for
starting and ending.
All right, I think that is a
trellis-oriented generator matrix.
Well, it is.
We found a matrix that has
distinct starting times and
ending times, so it is.
Now what's its state
branch complexity?
The state dimension is 0.
Now what are our spans now?
Two are the same, but
two are larger.
OK, so now when we count, we get
that the state complexity
goes 0, 1, 2, 3, there are
actually four that are now
active in the center.
3, 2, 1, 0.
OK, and that's worse than
we had before, at
least in one place.
If we look at the dimensions
of the branch spaces, which
I'm arguing is more fundamental,
then we get 1, 2,
3, again, 4, 4.
So the branch complexity is
now 16 rather than 8.
It's going to be more difficult,
definitely, to
decode this code with the
Viterbi algorithm.
This is a more complex
representation of an
effectively equivalent code.
Well, so is there--
so this is a bad permutation,
it's something I
didn't want to do.
Is it possible there's some good
permutation that would
reduce the complexity?
In general, when we're given a
block code, traditionally at
least, we think of it as the
coordinates as just being not
in any particular order.
We can write down a generator
matrix, but the view is that
any permutation of the symbol
times is perfectly legitimate.
Certainly, if we send it over a
memoryless channel, it's not
going to affect the performance
of the code, what
order we send the symbols in.
So we should certainly regard
all such codes as equivalent.
But we can affect the
complexity, for better or for
worse, so we should try to --
presumably, if we want a more
fundamental complexity metric
for the code, we want to find
the complexity of the least
complex trellis realization
under all permutations of the
coordinates.
All right, so that's a good
issue, but very little is
known about this issue.
It is known that finding the
best permutation of an
arbitrary linear code is
an NP-hard problem.
So this is going to be hard.
We know for some specific
classes of codes what the best
permutation is.
For instance, the Reed-Muller
codes are nice because it's
been proved by Kasami and
others that the standard
coordinate ordering, the one
that I've been using all along
based on this length doubling
construction, the u-u plus v
construction, gives you the
minimal trellis complexity.
All right, so we know what the
best ordering is for the
Reed-Muller codes.
And in a minute, I'm going to
prove what the best possible
we can get bounds--
in particular, the Muder bounds,
which I'm going to
discuss next--
which bound the best possible
complexity that
you could ever get.
And in some cases, we can find
coordinate orderings that meet
that bound, notably in the
case of the 24-12-8 Golay
code, we can find a coordinate
ordering that's very closely
related to the Reed-Muller
ordering such that
the bound is met.
And so we know that we've
found the best
complexity for that code.
It couldn't possibly
be any better.
But apart from certain very
nice cases like those, we
don't know.
For instance, take an
arbitrary BCH code.
What's the best coordinate
ordering for that?
We don't know.
So this is the open question in
this subject, and it's now
been open long enough and
enough smart people have
looked at it, and we've got this
NP-hardness result, so
that it looks like it's going
to stay open indefinitely.
All right, let me discuss,
however, this Muder bound,
because it's simple and
sometimes definitive.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Minimal branch
complexity or any other
measure that you like.
They all are quite fungible,
it turns out.
OK, The Muder bound.
Let's look at a particular code
and suppose we just know
its parameters, n, k, d.
Let's ask what the minimal
trellis complexity could be
for a particular coordinate
ordering, say, that divides --
we have a certain number of past
symbols, call it n_p, and
a certain number of future
symbols, n_f.
And I'm going to ask what the
minimum state complexity, or I
could also ask what's
the minimum
branch complexity for--
let me do now a state
complexity, going back to
where we started from, for a a
certain division in the past
and future.
To be concrete, let me take
the 24-12-8 Golay code.
It turns out that it's been
proved that all codes with
these parameters
are equivalent.
So we can just call this code
the binary Golay code.
And let's look for any division
into 16 future
coordinates and 8 past
coordinates.
So we don't know what the
ordering is going to be, but
we could say a few things.
Remember how we get the
state complexity.
We look for what's the dimension
of the past subcode.
So here's a generator for the
past subcode here, the code
whose support is the past.
We can ask what the dimension of
the future subcode is, and
then the dimension of the state
space is the dimension
of what's left.
So it's dimension of c minus
the dimension of the past
subcode minus the dimension
of the future subcode.
State-space theorem.
OK, but we know a few things
about this code.
We know what its length is and
we know what its minimum
distance is.
So for this particular case,
we have that c past is an
8-something-8 code, because its
minimum distance has got
to be at least as
great as this.
It's a subcode of this code.
So any non-zero code words in
this past subcode have to have
minimum weight of at least 8.
Correct?
All right.
And similarly, the future
subcode, in this
case, is a 16-k --
let's call this past --
k-future-8 code.
At least 8.
So that imposes some bounds on
the dimension of this code.
How large could the dimension
possibly be?
All right, anybody?
For the past subcode its
clearly, we have that k_p less
than or equal to 1.
We could have, at most,
one generator here.
And if there were one,
it would have to be
the all-1 code word.
Or the all-1 symbols here,
because it has
to have weight 8.
So that's all we can get.
For the future code--
well, I guess you don't know
this, but you can guess that
the Reed-Muller code with length
16 and minimum distance
8 is the best there is, that
distance 16, and that happens
to be true.
So k-future can't possibly be
better than 5, which is the
dimension of the Reed-Muller
code with those parameters.
For more general cases, you
have to look up tables on
bounds on the best codes that
have ever been found.
But certainly for code lengths
less than a 100, by this time
we pretty much know all
the best binary codes.
So we can look up in a table
what's the best code of length
16 and distance 8?
Well, it has five information
symbols, dimension five.
So we couldn't have more than
one dimension here and we
couldn't have more than five
dimensions here, so the
dimensional code itself is 12.
We have to say that the
dimension state-space is now
going to be greater
than equal to--
this is k_p minus 1 minus 5--
so, that's 6.
So there have to be at least 6
generators down here that have
support neither wholly on the
past nor wholly on the future
and therefore have to be
included in the state-space.
All right, that's the idea
of the Muder bound.
Now, we could do this for every
single state-space.
We simply need to know what the
dimension is of the best
code of each length with
minimum distance 8.
And we can do a similar thing
for every possible partition
in the past and future.
And that will give us a set of
bounds, and we go through that
exercise in the notes.
And I can write it on the
board, maybe for memory.
And OK, that tells us what
the best possible
state profile is.
Let me guess state dimension
profile is 0, 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
Then it goes down to 6, 7, 8,
9, then it goes down to 8.
This is at the central
state-space.
This is for dividing it in
the way that we just did.
Let's do this here.
For the central state-space,
what's the best k_p for a 12,
k_p, 8 code?
Let's make the past and
future both 12.
Anyone want to guess what
the best dimension is?
Let's think about it.
Let's think of a code that's
going to have to have
minimum weight 8.
So let's start out with g1.
And we'll just make that
look like that.
It's going to have length 12.
It's going to have to have at
least eight 1s, so let's make
them like that.
We want to add another 1 so
that the total code has a
minimum distance 8.
Subject to up to permutations,
there's only one
thing it can be.
We need another weight-8
generator, and it needs to
differ from this in at least
four places so that when we
take the mod 2 sum of these
two, it has distance 8.
And we want g1 plus g2.
This is really the only
way it can be.
Are you with me?
We have four code words in
this dimension 2 code.
And if they're going to have
minimum distance 8, they're
going to have to look like
this, subject to up to
permutation.
So from that little argument,
we conclude that, in this
case, this is less than
or equal to 2.
This is less than or equal to
2, the Muder bound becomes
that the dimension of
the state-space has
to be at least 8.
And so in the same way, and then
it becomes symmetrical on
the other side.
So I'm pretty sure
I get it right.
And from memory, that's the best
possible state dimension
profile, dot dot dot.
And we actually know a
coordinate ordering for the
Golay code, a generator matrix
for the Golay code, that gives
this state dimension profile.
So from that, we can conclude
that we know an optimum
coordinate ordering for
the Golay code.
I just want you to get the
essence of the argument here.
You with me?
For branch spaces, the argument
is much the same.
Remember in branch spaces,
we basically --
let me say it in a slightly
different way than we did
before -- we take the past
to be up to time k.
And we have the symbol time,
which is just one time in here
for the actual symbol
we're looking at.
And the future is one unit
shorter than it was for the
state-space.
So when we compute the
branch dimension, the
past goes up to k.
So this is 0 and before k.
And the future goes from
k plus one up to n.
So this is what the matrix
looks like for this.
And the effect over here is that
the future subcode now is
one unit shorter.
So let's do the same
calculation here.
If we look at a time where we
have 12 in the past, this one
time, the 13th symbol time that
we're actually looking at
and then 11 more in the future,
the past subcode,
again, could have dimension up
to 2 because it has length 12
and minimum distance 8.
The future subcode now has a
shorter length and by this
little argument I went
through here.
If we take out one of these
coordinates, it's
not going to work.
So if we only have length 11,
the future subcode is the
dimension --
still can only be 1.
We can't possibly add another
second generator in there.
And so the dimension of the
branch space has to be vastly
greater than or equal
to 9, at this point.
OK, so the Golay code has branch
complexity of at least
512, we conclude.
And, in fact, this best possible
branch dimension
profile looks like this.
The branches are in
the middle here.
They're 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 6.
Basically we have generators
which look like this.
And then there's one that comes
down, there are three
more that goes up and
one that comes down.
And from that, we get 1,
2, 3, 4, 6, 7, 7, 8 --
that can't be right.
Goes down 7, goes up, it's still
7, then it goes up to 8,
9, and 9, 9, 9.
Something like that.
That one's probably wrong,
and symmetrically.
Where this 9 is the one
we just calculated.
Similarly, if you come down to
the neighbor of this 6, it's
got a merge on one side,
a diverge on the other
side, and that's 7.
OK, so we conclude that the
Golay code has branch
dimension not less than
512 within 9.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Suppose we take past
and future separated by 12, 12
in the past, 12 in the future.
Suppose we did it as they did
in [UNINTELLIGIBLE] state?
PROFESSOR: OK, but that's not
the way we do branches.
We've got to isolate
the symbol time.
AUDIENCE: Suppose we took
12-branch-12 and we calculate
the state complexity,
that's 8.
And then we took 13 and 11, we
get the state complexity 9.
PROFESSOR: All right, you're
saying if we do this, we
should get the state
complexity 9.
And that's correct, we do.
AUDIENCE: The maximum of those
two numbers, is it the same as
branch complexity?
PROFESSOR: It turns out
to be in this case.
AUDIENCE: Not always?
PROFESSOR: Not always.
But if we go to 14, 10, then
it turns out we can add
another one here because we can
add another generator that
looks like something
like this.
1, 1, 0, 0, 1, 1, 1,
1, 0, 0, 1, 1.
So if we have two more units, we
can add another generator.
Sort of Reed-Muller style.
And so this goes up to 3 and
this goes down to 8.
AUDIENCE: So the branch
complexity has to be at least
the maximum of those
two, right?
PROFESSOR: Obviously, right.
And really, together these give
you the story of where
the thing has to diverge
and merge.
In this case, this is a
self-dual code, so you only do
one at each time.
So with this sort of
thing, you can
pretty well pin it down.
Again, I don't know how far
to take this lecture.
I'm really just trying to get
to you the idea of the Muder
bound from this kind of
argument, therefore we can get
a bound on the best possible
state dimension profile and
the best possible branch
complexity profile.
If you compute this bound and
you're able to find an actual
generator matrix that meets this
bound, you know you've
found the best one.
But this rarely happens, this
is a very special code.
It's not the way you prove the
optimality of the longer
Reed-Muller codes, they're
not good enough to --
this really assumes that you
can get the best possible
sub-codes at every point.
And you can imagine that's
very hard to do.
It would be a very special case
where you can optimize
this for every single possible
cut between past and future.
OK, so that's the Muder bound.
And you have a homework exercise
on that as well.
Oh, there's another case where
we can find what the best
possible trellis
complexity is.
It's MDS codes over GFq, and
you're going to do that on the
homework as well.
And there, we basically show
that an MDS code, its n, k, d
are such that it has to have
the worst possible state
complexity and branch
complexity.
So because it's such a
tightly-packed code, in
Hamming distance sense, it
forces you to have the worst
possible complexity that
you could have.
In other words, you have
diverges immediately and as
long as you can, and then
they're all packed together on
the left side and the merges are
all packed together on the
right side, and that's the
only way it can be.
I'm just speaking very
impressionistically.
But you'll see what I mean when
you get to the homework,
if you haven't done
it already.
OK, so we also know MDS codes,
we know their trellis
complexity and it's terrible.
We can't get any effective
reduction.
Really, over exhaustive decoding
methods with MDS
codes, we find that the trellis
complexity is like
either q to the k or
q to the n minus k,
depending on which is less.
So that's as bad as it
could possibly be.
So if the trellis doesn't help
for MDS codes, in general
cyclic codes --
which were subject to a lot of
study -- if we put the code
into cyclic form, which if you
remember Reed-Solomon codes
and BCH codes can always be put
into cyclic form, at least
the shortened versions
of them.
In that case, the generator
matrix looks
like this one up here.
It looks like x, x, x, x, x, x,
x, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, x,
x, x, x, x, x, x, 0, 0,
x, x, x, x, x, x, x.
In other words, the generators
are just cyclic
shifts of one another.
Down to x, x, x, x, x,
x, x, 0, 0, 0, 0.
That is a generator matrix that
is a trellis-oriented
generator matrix because all
the starting times are
different and all the stopping
times are different.
So this is the trellis-oriented
generator
matrix for cyclic code, and
it's in the coordinate
ordering in which
it is cyclic.
And it's always going to have
this worst case -- all the
branch diverges are going to
occur over here and you may
get nothing for a while.
And then all the merges over
here, which if it's a rate
less than 1/2 code, this means
that the trellis complexity is
basically going to
be 2 to the k.
Or if it's a high-rate code, it
means it's going to be 2 to
the n minus k.
And again, you get no
improvement over some
exhaustive minimum distance
decoding, or maximum
likelihood decoding.
So cyclic is very bad from
a trellis point of view.
So I think that's about
all the general
comments I can make.
The very last thing that
I want to mention is
we now want to --
all right, so through this nice
little theory, we've got
a way of trellis decoding
(maximum likelihood decoding),
via the Viterbi algorithm,
of block codes.
And now, did we achieve any
improvements in terms of
performance versus complexity
versus the convolutional codes
that we looked at previously?
And the basic answer is, no.
If you compare the tables,
convolutional are always better.
I'll just say it.
You can imagine that there have
been long debates in the
fraternity, and that certainly
some of the motivation for
trellis decoding of block codes
was, oh, gee, now we
have a good way to decode block
codes, just like we did
for convolutional codes.
And maybe now we'll find that
block codes are worthwhile.
But the answer is they're not.
I should put this comparison
into Chapter 10.
You can actually get this
comparison by taking the table
-- for instance, for
Reed-Muller codes.
In terms of performance versus
complexity, Reed-Muller codes
are very good.
I would say as a general
statement, they're the best
block codes that we know of, in
terms of performance versus
trellis decoding complexity,
because they have this nice
structure that gives them very
low-complexity trellises for
their n, k, d parameters.
So in this sense, it's
a fair comparison.
Reed-Muller codes are the best
general class we know of in
terms of trellis complexity.
We compare them against binary
convolutional codes and
they're not nearly as good.
I've already talked about
the comparison.
It seems like a very fair
comparison to take our rate
1/2 four-state convolutional
code example, which had
distance 5, which had not only a
nominal coding gain of 4 dB,
but it also has an effective
coding gain of 4 dB.
And for a block code, this 8,
4, 4 code is a very fair
comparison.
It's also rate 1/2, so it has
the same spectral efficiency.
It also has a four-state trellis
that looks very much
like a rate 1/2 convolutional
code trellis.
But it turns out it only has
minimum distance of 4 rather
than 5, so its nominal coding
gain is only 3 dB
rather than 4 dB.
Its effective coding
gain is less.
Its effective coding gain is
2.6 dN because it has 14
nearest neighbors, which is a
3 1/2 nearest neighbors per
bit, and that costs you
about 4/10 of a dN.
And so really, you compare
the performance of the
convolutional to the block code,
that's very much better.
Another head-to-head comparison
might be between
the 32, 16, 8 Reed-Muller
code.
That's a rate 1/2 code.
It's a very good one, it's
known to be the best with
those parameters, n, k, d.
So what's its nominal
coding gain?
Anyone?
It has rate 1/2, minimum
distance 8, its
nominal coding gain is?
Hello?
6 dB.
You take the rate times
the minimum distance--
1/2 times 8, you get 4.
So that's the nominal
coding gain.
A factor of 4, which in
dB terms is 6 dB.
But again, it has lots of
minimum-weight code words.
It has 620 minimum-weight
code words.
And therefore, the number of
minimum-weight code words per
bit is 39, which is between five
and six factors of 3, so
it costs you 5 and 1/2 times 0.2
dB in terms of effective
coding gain, which brings you
down to an effective coding
gain of 4.9 dB.
I assume you're all
very fluent in
doing these, as I am.
And what's its complexity?
If you look its state
complexity, let's take--
we're looking at
the 32, 16, 8.
And all the Reed-Muller codes
have four section trellises,
you proved that this week.
If you just measure the state
complexity of four places,
equally spaced with four equal
sections, then all the
trellises wind up looking
like this, for a general
Reed-Muller trellis --
a four-section trellis.
And for the 32, 16, 8, it
turns out you get eight
parallel sections like that
with eight of these each.
In any case, it's 64 states at
each of these boundaries.
So you could say it's
a 64-state trellis.
But if you're more honest, just
exactly as with the Golay
code calculation we went
through, you find that the
maximum branch complexity
is 512.
So branch complexity is 512.
OK, and its nominal coding gain
we said is 6 dB and its
effective coding
gain is 4.9 dB.
OK, so let's look for a
convolutional code of rate 1/2
that has a coding gain
of about 5 or 6 dB.
And how far do we have to go?
We actually only have
to go up to a--
well, a 32-state code
has an effective
coding gain of 5.6 dB.
A 64-state code we can get up to
an effective coding gain of
about 6 dB.
In fact, the 64-state rate 1/2
convolutional code was a
standard for a very long time,
first in space communications
and then in much more general
applications.
This was the code that Linkabit
Corporation --
Jacobs and Viterbi --
rode to fame and fortune, made
their first pile before they
went on to found Qualcomm,
where they made
a much bigger pile.
And so this was their--
they call it k equals 7.
But in my terms, nu equals
6, a 64-state rate 1/2
convolutional code.
So let's take that rate 1/2
64-state convolutional code,
just with the standard
trellis.
So its branch complexity
is 128 at every time.
It has a more regular structure
than this guy.
Its nominal coding gain is --
there are actually two of them,
and I don't remember.
There's one of them that has a
nominal coding gain of 7, the
other one is 6.5.
So it's at least 6.5 dB.
And its effective coding gain
is still 6.1 dB and it's
clearly much better than this.
If you kind of try to plot a
graph of this, you'll see that
the effective coding gains of
convolutional codes with the
same state complexity is at
least one dB better, as a
general trend, than that
of block codes.
And of course, if you do it in
terms of branch complexity,
it's an even better
comparison.
So what happened was there was
about a decade of effort on
basically finding good trellis
representations of block
codes, and the net of it was
that they couldn't get
anywhere close to finding
anything as good as
convolutional codes.
Although, it's a nice little
piece of theory.
And sometimes you want to block
codes for other reasons.
Sometimes you want
short blocks.
Sometimes you're limited to
a block of less than 100.
And in that case, you're
certainly not going to do
better in terms of n, k, d than
the best block code of a
length 100.
Why are convolutional
codes better?
First of all, they obviously
naturally are well-adapted to
the trellis idea.
They are linear time invariant
machines that just have very
nice, regular trellises.
So they're naturally adapted.
But also, they have exactly
the right--
a rate 1/2 code is diverge,
merge, diverge, merge,
diverge, merge forever.
If you want to make it into a
block code, you can terminate
it or you can tail-bite it,
which is something we're going
to talk about shortly.
But whichever way you do it, to
make it into a block code,
you lose something.
The termination, you don't lose
minimum distance, but you
do lose rate.
You have to put in some dummy
information symbols, so the
rate becomes less than 1/2 if
you terminate this code.
Nonetheless, as I believe I
commented earlier, that's a
good way to come up with good
block codes, is to terminate a
good convolutional code.
If you choose the parameters
right, you can come up with
pretty good codes.
But nonetheless, in terms of
block code parameters, you're
not going to do better than what
50 years of block code,
algebraic coding theory
has come up with.
So for short block codes with
length less than 100, really
the best we know of right
now-- let's say 128--
is to pick a good Reed-Muller
code or BCH code, find its
best trellis and do maximum
likelihood decoding.
It used to be that you thought
of 64 states as a lot of
states, but clearly, technology
has progressed.
And now you wouldn't blink at
1,000 states or maybe even
8,000 or 16,000 states.
The biggest Viterbi decoder that
was ever built had 2 to
the 14 states for a space
program out of JPL.
So anyway, it's doable now.
If you needed the best possible
performance and you
were constrained in block
length, you'd pick the best
block code at the rate that
you wanted, and the best
minimum distance at that rate,
and the best effective coding
gain, and you'd do maximum
likelihood decoding with
trellis decoding.
But if that's not usually
the situation --
the situation in data
communications, because
usually more you have a stream
of data or a packet length of
at least 1,000, and then it
would certainly be better to
use convolutional codes.
And trellis decoding is --
as long as we're in this
class of techniques.
Where we're finally going in
this course is to the new
codes that have been developed
in the past decade,
capacity-approaching codes,
turbo codes, low-density
parity-check codes.
These are simple enough to do
so that as soon as you get
past the small codes, length
less than 100, you would
switch over to that track.
You would use a
capacity-approaching code.
But we don't know
about them yet.
I guess that's the end of my
lecture on this, so it's a
very good place for questions
about state-of-the-art, where
we've been, where we're going.
The floor is always open.
But that was all I was going
to say about Chapter 10.
Chapter 11, Codes on Graphs.
And now we begin our final
stretch drive towards
capacity-approaching codes,
which is going to be the
subject of the next
three chapters.
Chapter 11 is sort of the
beginnings of codes on graphs.
We're going to look at some
elementary representations.
One of the ones we're going
to look at is a trellis
representation.
That's one of the reasons we've
been going through this
theory, is we're going to,
again, encounter trellises as
a natural, simple, cycle-free,
graphical representation that,
in some sense, is about as good
as you can ever do, as
long as you don't allow
cycles in graphs.
But then we're going to go on
to graphs with cycles, which
is really the way to
understand these
capacity-approaching codes.
So in this chapter, we'll
start the subject, we'll
introduce graphical
representations of codes in
more general terms.
In Chapter 12, we'll talk about
the generic decoding
algorithms for codes on graphs
called sum-product and min-sum
decoding algorithms.
And then in Chapter 13, we'll
talk about the actual classes
of capacity-approaching codes
that people have developed,
what their graphs are, how
you decode them --
I hope in enough detail so that
you'll get a good sense
for how all this works.
So that's where we're going.
What are we talking about
when we're talking
about codes on graphs?
There are many styles of
representations of codes, and
at this point, for linear codes,
we have seen a number
of ways we can characterize
a code.
One of the ways is just by
giving a set of generators for
the code, k generators
for an n, k code.
And that sort of characterizes
the code.
Another way is to basically give
the generator matrix for
the dual code, the h matrix,
which becomes the parity-check
matrix for the code.
So we can also characterize
the code by a
dual-generator matrix.
That's a particularly efficient
way to do it if you
have a high-rate code like a
single parity-check code, it's
better to say that the dual code
is the repetition code
and it's the set of all code
words that are orthogonal to
the all-one code word.
That's the simplest
characterization of the single
parity-check code.
In other words, that the sum
of all bits is equal to 0.
That's what orthogonal to the
all-one code word means.
So that's a simpler
representation than giving a
generator matrix formed for the
single parity-check code.
Or now we have this trellis
representation, which
certainly looks like a more
graphical representation.
It certainly characterizes the
code in a very direct way.
What does a trellis do?
It basically displays all the
code words on a graph.
There's a 1:1 correspondence
between the set of all paths,
from the root to the n-node
in the graph and the code.
So that's another way to
characterize the code.
So now we're going to go to
higher level graphical
representations.
As a first step, we talk about
behavioral realizations.
Again, a term from system
theory, closely identified
with Jan Willems, who promoted
this way of representing
linear systems.
In linear system theory terms,
the basic idea in behavioral
systems theory is you describe a
system by the set of all its
possible trajectories.
What are all the things
it can do?
And now, how do you characterize
the trajectories?
Often, you characterize them by
a set of local constraints.
You can think of it as equations
that the system has
to satisfy.
Ordinarily, they're differential
equations or
partial differential equations
or something.
And if it satisfies all of those
constraints, then it's a
trajectory that satisfies all
these partial differential
equations, is a valid
trajectory.
So you can set up the whole
system that way.
So it characterizes a system
by its trajectories.
That's the fundamental thing.
And it characterizes
trajectories --
legitimate, valid
by local constraints.
Let me get a little
bit more concrete.
In coding terms, by
trajectories we
just mean code words.
So this is a very compatible
notion with the way we've been
talking in coding.
What is a code?
It's simply a set
of code words.
So if we simply say, what are
all the possible code words?
We have to find all the
trajectories of the code, and
we have a very explicit example
of that in trellises.
We've called the paths
trajectories through a trellis.
What is a code?
It's simply the set of
all valid code words.
And how do we characterize
the valid code words?
Well, in each of
these styles --
the generator, parity-check,
trellis style --
the code words are the code
words that satisfy certain
equations or constraints.
For instance, the generator
representation --
we've said a code is the set of
all uG, such that u is in a
field to the k.
That's a generator matrix style
of representing a code.
In other words, we can say it's
the set of all y, such
that y equals uG for
some u in Fk.
Or we can say it's all y, such
that y minus uG equals 0 for
some u in Fk.
So it's the set of all y that,
together with some auxiliary
variables which are not part
of the code word --
here they're input variables,
if you like, or information
bits, information symbols.
We'll come to think of these
as state variables because
they're hidden, they're not
visible, they're just an
auxiliary part of
the description.
They're code words that,
together with some auxiliary
variables that, in this case,
can be freely chosen, satisfy
a certain set of linear
homogeneous equations.
Something that's even better in
the behavioral style is a
parity-check representation.
Let me put that up.
In a parity-check
representation, we say the
code is the set of all y, such
that y H transpose equals 0,
where H is the generator matrix
of the dual code.
This is sometimes called a
kernel representation.
y is in the kernel of this
linear transformation.
We see H transpose is a linear
transformation from n-tuples
to n minus k-tuples, and the
ones whose image is 0 under
this transformation, the ones
that map to 0 are legitimate
code words.
So this is a kernel
representation, this is an
image representation.
Here, we view the code as
the image of the linear
transformation, which is
characterized by g, where the
inputs are free.
But the parity-check
representation is much more
explicitly, we don't need any
auxiliary variables here.
It's simply the set of n-tuples
that satisfy a
certain set of linear
homogeneous equations.
So this maybe is a place where
we start and, of course, it's
the place where Bob Gallager
started when he did
low-density parity-check codes,
which are a principal
class of capacity-approaching
codes.
Then in either case, we
characterize the code by, in
one case, directly satisfying
some equations.
In the other case, here we say
that the total behavior is the
set of all y and u, such that
y minus uG equals 0.
So we're going to take the set
of all n-tuples and k-tuples,
such that y minus uG equals 0.
And we say that's the total
behavior of the code.
The set of all y's and u's that
satisfy this equation is
the total behavior.
And then we'll say the code word
is just the projection of
the behavior on the y's.
In other words, it's the set of
all y's, such that this is
satisfied first some u.
And that's an equivalent
description.
So the general setup, going
back and forth, is that we
have the observed symbols.
And in the coding case, this
will always just be the n
symbols in the code word.
These are the ones that
we really care about.
But we're also going to have
some hidden or auxiliary
symbols or state variables,
hidden variables, which, in
this case, for instance,
are the u's.
And we can introduce these at
our convenience, just to make
a good realization.
So we have two types of symbols:
the observed, or
external variables--
sometimes these are
called external
variables, internal variables.
Again, in system theory, you're
consistently seeing this.
There are some that
we can actually
observe, interact with.
These are the observed symbols,
and then there are
internal variables to the
system, very often called
state variables, which we can't
directly see but which
are part of the description of
the system, as in this case.
The whole system, we find the
set of all internal and
external variables that satisfy
a set of constraints.
But we only care about the
patterns of observed variables
that are consistent with some
set of internal variables.
So the final element here
in this general setup is
constraints, which in this
case are simply linear
homogeneous equations on
subsets of variables.
So let me go through similar
kinds of examples,
as I do in the notes.
But let me maybe build up from
the simplest one first,
parity-check representation of
our favorite 8, 4, 4 code.
In this case, the parity-check
matrix is the same, we can
take it to be the same as
the generator matrix.
Since, by now, we like
trellis-oriented generator
matrices, we'll take that one.
So to get very explicit, so the
code is the set of all y,
such that y H transpose equals
0, and y is 8-tuple.
So it's the set of all code
words that satisfy these
parity-check constraints.
The first one is y1 plus y2
plus y3 plus y4 equals 0.
That's orthogonality to
this first code word.
The second one is y2 plus y4
plus y5 plus y7 equals 0.
The third equation is y3 plus
y4 plus y5 plus y6 equals 0.
And the fourth is y5 plus y6
plus y7 plus y8 equals 0.
If I have any 8-tuple y, such
that the elements of the
8-tuples satisfy these four
equations, then it's a code
word, if and only if.
A very explicit description
of the code.
Now let's go onto a graph of
behavioral realization.
So it's very natural to draw the
following kind of graph of
this realization.
We let the y's --
y1, y2, y3, y4 --
sorry, I've changed the
index set, haven't I?
I get 1 through 8 now.
I'm just going to make these
into vertices of my graph.
So here we have symbols, and I'm
going to make a bipartite
graph, and over here I'm going
to have equations, or
constraints, or checks.
And I have four checks, which
I'm going to draw like this.
The first check is that y1 plus
y2 plus y3 plus y4 equals
0, so I'll just draw
that like this.
That means the same
thing as this.
The second one is y2 plus y4
plus y5 plus y7 equals 0.
And the third one
is these four --
two, three, four.
And the last one
is these four.
This, this, this, this.
It's done more nicely
in the notes.
This is called a Tanner graph,
after an extremely good paper
by Michael Tanner in 1981, which
was about the only paper
of any consequence in this
subject between Gallager's
thesis in 1961 and the
rediscovery of low-density
parity-check codes
around 1995.
That's a graphical picture
of these equations.
And what do we think of?
You can think of testing
an 8-tuple.
Take an arbitrary, binary
8-tuple, think of these as
memory elements, put the bits
of that 8-tuple in here, and
then ask if all these checks
are satisfied.
Since we're talking mod 2
arithmetic, we're basically
asking if there are an even
number of 1s attached to each
of these checks.
If and only if that's true,
we've got a code 8-tuple.
From the set of all 256
8-tuples, we find 16 that
actually satisfy these checks,
and that's the code.
That's one way of describing
the code.
So that's how the graph is
associated with local
constraints.
Well call them local, each of
these constraints, because
each of them only involves
four of the symbols.
In a much larger graph, a
low-density parity-check code,
the idea is that there are not
very many symbols that are
checked by each check.
The graph is sparse,
in that sense.
But we're not quite there yet.
So that's pretty simple.
Let me do a generator
representation.
This is going to be a little bit
more complicated because
we have these auxiliary
input variables.
But that doesn't really
complicate it very much.
I keep using this 8, 4, 4 code
just to emphasize that a
single code can be described
in many different ways.
We're going to wind up with
half a dozen different
graphical representations of
this code, and they can be
grouped according to style.
So again, we could use our
favorite generator matrix for
our favorite code.
It looks like that.
Now what do we mean?
What are our constraints now?
Well, now we have some hidden
variables, ui, and we have y1
is equal to u1.
We're going to basically
multiply this by u1.
I've got some u1, u2, u3,
u4 multiplying this.
So y1 is u1, y2 is u1 plus u2,
y3 is equal to u1 plus u3, y4
is equal to u1 plus u2
plus u3, so forth.
y5 is u2 plus u3 plus u4,
y6 is u2 plus u4.
I jumped one here.
This is u3 plus u4, y7 is u2
plus u4, and y8 equals u8.
And you will agree that the code
is described, if I can
find any pair, (y,u), such that
this is satisfied, then y
is an element of the code.
I can choose u freely,
that is the input.
If I find a y at any u, such
that these equations are
satisfied, then I've
found a code word.
And that's an if and only if.
So that's another
characterization of the code.
And its Tanner graph
looks like this.
Here in this case, we have
hidden variables.
So let's put the inputs--
or, we'll see they can also be
thought of as states, but
they're hidden variables
that we don't actually
see in the code word.
u1, u2, u3, u4.
You can think of these as
free-driving variables.
And to get y1, here's
what we do.
We're going to take y1 and we're
going to create a mod 2
sum of some of these inputs.
In this case, it's just
u1, so I can draw it
as a straight through.
But in general, I'm going to
have to make a combination to
get all of these.
So I have eight symbols
over here --
code symbols --
and again, some constraints
that have to be satisfied.
Equations, mod 2 sums, y8.
And I just, again,
draw a picture.
y2 is u1 plus u2,
so u1 plus u2.
these sum to give y2.
And so, again, if I put down
some u's, put down some y's,
test whether all these sums are
correct, then I will have
tested whether I found a valid
behavior or trajectory.
Next one is u1 plus u3.
The next one is u1, u2, u3.
The next one is u2, u3, u4.
The next one is u3, u4.
The next one is u2, u4.
And the last one is
just that one.
OK, so that's another graph
whose constraints
describe the code word.
Here it's helpful to start to
introduce the following
convention.
We fill in the circle of the
variables that we actually
want to see, and we leave
these open, the free
variables over here.
Some people would call it a
generalized Tanner graph.
In the notes, I just call
this Tanner graph 2.
Tanner didn't actually consider
state variables.
This was introduced into
graphical models by a guy
named Wiberg in his PhD thesis
in Sweden in about 1995.
And that was a huge
contribution, to have hidden
variables as well as observed
variables, because otherwise
you couldn't really draw a
generator representation as a
graph, or a trellis
representation.
You need hidden state
variables.
So those are two graphical
styles, and the idea here is
that every set of 12 variables,
such that these
eight equations are satisfied,
gives you a
legitimate code word.
Here you can easily think
of this as --
you notice that we've described
these as passive
constraints.
It's not an input-output,
block diagram type of
representation.
It causes cause-effects.
In this case, it
implicitly is.
How would you actually implement
this generator
representation?
You implement it by picking
four input bits and then
seeing what code words
they generate.
In other words, there's a very
definite input-output relation
here, where we could make this
into a directed graph by
drawing arrows here.
In general, in our graphical
models, we're
not going to do this.
The behavioral style is very
much not in this spirit.
But in this case,
we clearly can.
So if you actually wanted to
generate all the code words --
that's why it's called a
generator representation --
you simply jump through all 16
possibilities here and you
generate all 16 code words.
Or if you wanted to do a
simulation, generate code
words, this is the way
you would do it.
This has easy cause
and effect style.
The kernel representation
is much more implicit.
What is the cause and
the effect here?
In this case, it's actually
possible to find a cause and
effect representation.
It turns out that these four
bits can be taken as
information bits, or these
four places form an
information set.
So suppose we choose these four
bits, and it turns out
that for this graph, we can
trace through as follows.
These three bits going
into this zero-sum,
these all go in.
That determines this
output, right?
d minus 1, if d is the degree
of the zero-sum node, any d
minus 1 inputs determine the
last output, because the
parity-check has to check.
So that determines this one,
which then determines y4.
Now, knowing that, we know all
but one input here, because I
also have this one.
And that determines this, and
I think it probably also
determines this.
I now have three of the
four inputs here,
so I can get this.
And anyway, by tracing through
it I can create a directed
graph that gives me
a cause and effect
relationship from here.
But it's much more implicit and
it can't always be done.
Sometimes you can find an
information set that works
with these particular set of
equations and sometimes you
can't, sometimes
you get stuck.
We can come back to this when
we talk about binary erasure
channel and stopping sets.
In this case, given these four,
you can determine the
remaining four.
If you think of it in equation
terms, if you're given y1, y2,
y3, you can basically go through
a Gaussian elimination
of these equations and find
y4, y6, y7 and y8.
So you can regard y1, y2,
y3, and y5 as inputs.
This is much more the behavioral
style, where it's
just simply any n-tuple that
satisfies the constraints is a
legitimate n-tuple.
This is more cause and effect
style over here.
Since we're at the end, let me
just introduce one more thing.
This is a bipartite graph.
We basically have a graph with
two types of nodes, one
representing variables, one
representing constraints.
And the edges always go between
a variable and a
constraint.
So that's what we mean
by a bipartite graph.
There are two types of vertices,
and all the edges
connect one type of vertex to
another type of vertex.
So is this over here.
I've drawn it in a way where
it's not so obvious.
In a generalized Tanner graph,
you'd put all the variables
over on one side and the
constraints over
on the other side.
In this case, these observed
variables go naturally with
the constraints, so I
put them over here.
But I could have put them over
here and you would see this is
also a bipartite graph.
So this is the general
character.
What do we think of the edges
as doing in this graph?
We think of the edges as
conducting the variables that
they're associated with.
So all of these edges, in
fact, convey u1 to this
constraint.
We could, if we wanted to, label
all of the edges with
their associated variables.
That's what they mean.
They mean here that u1
equals y1, or that u1
plus u2 equals y2.
So the edges just serve for
communication in this graph.
There's another style of graph,
which I introduced, and
therefore, people --
not me -- but other people have
called it a Forney graph.
I call it a normal graph.
The difference is that basically
the vertices all
equal constraints, and the edges
represent variables.
And it has certain advantages
that have led to it being used
more and more.
Let me just indicate how we go
from a graph of this style to
a graph of this style.
We basically just make all the
variables into equality
constraints.
So in this case, I draw
y1, y2, and so forth.
I put a little dongle on them
to indicate that they
communicate with the
outside world.
They are observed, external
variables.
And then I put a little equality
constraint that says
all of the variables attached to
this constraint have to be
the same, which is really
doing the same thing.
Otherwise, the topology of
the graph looks the same.
These are, again, zero-sum
constraints, or parity-check
constraints, and the
connections are
done just as before.
I forget.
I'm not going to do
them all out.
The only change, in this case,
is to replace external
variables by an equality
constraint in this.
So the equality constraint
basically says this edge still
equals y1, this edge
still equals y2.
That's what the equality
constraint means.
Everything tied to
that equality
constraint has to be equal.
So we can think of these as just
replicas of this original
variable out here.
So far, you don't see any
reason to prefer this.
If I do it in this graph, then,
again, I get equality
constraints here.
I get zero-sum constraints,
again, over here.
Eight of them.
And in this case, I can just
represent the external
variables directly by these
little dongles.
And again, I have the
same graph here.
You still probably don't see
that there's very much
difference and, in
fact, I'd agree.
There's hardly any difference
between these two styles.
So forth.
This is the normal graph that's
equivalent to this
Tanner graph, it's obtained
in the same way.
If I wanted to do it more
painstakingly, I would put
equality constraints for each
of these, I'd put little
external variables, and then
I'd see I don't really need
the equality constraints.
So I can just compress it
into y1 through y8.
The advantages, I will say, of
the normal graph will appear
as we go along.
The main advantage is that you
can prove a very nice duality
theorem for normal graphs --
that basically shows the duality
between generator and
parity-check constraints.
But to say anything about that
right now would just
hand-waving, so we'll come
back to this next week.
See you in a week, have
a nice weekend.